ah c'est normal parce que c'est vrai que
vous étiez bien vous étiez bien ici mais
vous allez revenir à la rentrée
mais franchement vous voulez pas me
chanter une petite chanson pour enfants
ça va très bien se passer je suis très
content
mais je suis je suis je suis émue aussi
parce que je sens qu'il y a un torrent
quelque chose donc je suis ému donc je
profite là beaucoup d'émotions cette
dernière même si c'est pas une dernière
définitive parce que vraiment le comment
dire l'ambiance l'énergie et
l'adrénaline qu'on a sur cette émission
on l'a retrouvé nulle part d'autres et
quoi qu'il en soit
et je voulais vraiment vous dire que que
quand j'étais dans ma région en Alsace
et que je faisais uniquement Fort Boyard
et que les gens me connaissaient que
pour blanche et pour rouge bah c'est
vous qui avez su révélé Delphine vous
m'avez pris sous votre aile et vous me
protéger et merci beaucoup vraiment
c'est beau tu vois quand tu vas te
retrouver seul avec les requins là